Hồi thống Mỹ yêu đôn ra trông em bản thẩm 8 cho biết, quy định trấm giữ trên sử và yên ràng sẽ được lưu ra thông qua thảo lệ trông
dựa Washington và tà vị trông vui cạnh xứng đột tại Trung Lông tiếp tục lâu thang.
Phát biểu trong cuộc phòng vấn về bảo tờ times of insurance, ông Trump nói thơi đẹp với thúc trên sử sẽ làm một quy định trông
từ 2 phía với thủ tưởng Israan Benjamin, tại Rauh, đồng thời cho biết 2 bên đang rưỡi chỉ chào lỗi thưởng suyên về dịch biến của trên.
Trên thường đẹp, Israan tiếp tục mọi giống chứa sẽ quần sự khi tiền hàng không cách vào thủ đô về rút của libang,
lỗi rằng một tiêu là các chi quy của lực lượng quốc thuộc về đình kếm mạng hồi giảo iran, theo bộ y tế libang
các cuộc tấn công trong tôn đã khiến khoảng 30% trên mạng trong độ có tà mấy bà trẻ em và bộ mi hai thu nước.
Con lỗi Israan cũng sát nhận 2 bí xí nước này kể mạng trong ra trang đẹp mi in năm libang.
Và thế Iran, nước này cho biết in nhân một chăm lẽ tư người thêm mạng và 3 mạng người bị thương khi tổ trên Iris để nha của nước này bị tổ ngầm bị đánh chim.
Hồi khơi xuyên gà trong bộ biến của tế hồi tổn chứa.
Chòp khi đó vào bộ đúng bớt của ngài đứa tin, Washington đang cần nhắc khả năng trình.
Thái lực lực lực lực lực lực nhấm.
Nhằm kìm xuất lực uran lùm làm giấu, và nấc độ trên tàu vụ khí của Iran, dù thủ tình này chưa được xanh nhận được lập.